this is one of the thousands of
unregulated unmonitored mines in the DRC
it's crawling with children working like
modern-day slaves a 12-hour long day of
punishing work may earn them the
equivalent of a pound although one of
the poorest countries on earth DRC is
rich in minerals but a history of brutal
colonial exploitation looks like being
repeated now in 2017 much of its mined
by hand with rudimentary tools in harsh
potentially hazardous conditions and
wretched whether or not the rush is on
for a mineral the DRC has in great
abundance cobalt and it's fast becoming
more precious than gold it's a critical
ingredient in lithium-ion batteries
which power smartphones and laptops an
army of children are at the heart of the
mining production wearing no shoes and
in the most wretched conditions dorsen
is ordered to retrieve the sack his
forgotten
there's an urgency now the rains make
this dangerous work even more risky and
door sounds told in no uncertain terms
he risks a beating if he messes up again
Dawson with Richard beside him have
worked all day we're eight and 11 years
old even astonishing work doesn't
guarantee enough for food
Dawson hasn't eaten for two days now
this is what helpless looks like and
he's one of the children making millions
for multinational corporations in
America and China whilst they suffer in
squalor for this they'll get maybe eight
British pence a day latest bulletin in
the turn out of here - guess I'm going
home
[Music]
[Applause]
magic
the tunnels are dug by hand with no
supports they frequently collapse
especially during rain the miners climb
down using holes carved in the rock and
no safety equipment this most precious
of minerals is often extracted and
sorted by tiny hands
they don't wear gloves or masks yet the
World Health Organization says exposure
to cobalt and breathing in its dust
fumes can cause long-term health
problems we visited five different mines
across the south of DRC and cloud all
use child workers monikers the youngest
worker in this group at just four but
even those barely able to walk have lost
their childhoods to mining nataly's 12
years old or now what my fingers hurt
she tells us miles away on a different
site macumba Mateo shows us the cobalt
tunnel he's done with three of his
friends it's physically tough work they
removed all this rock by hand over
nearly four months it's incredibly
insecure for them although this is
really rich in minerals and it's going
down just 15 meters there's no support
bars there's there's they have no
protective masks or protective equipment
at all and right at the bottom I can see
water
it's his villages water which Macumba is
convinced has caused his health problems
after a lifetime of drinking it he has a
huge tumor on his throat got on it and
played it reveille Akito that won't keep
evil at all Marty and red they give to
this he he suffer yep I know
there are countless reports of other
health problems from those living nearby
and working on the minds compulsory let
FX y mingle my my affects your journey
to Naraku Cosmo man to become a career
sanatanpur my fish arugula Guinea wanna
be my Bhutan Bhutto in the dirt no not
on my kuzey Lena to come in when
intimate area these twins are just two
days old and although small so far
they're healthy to the relief of their
mother among my man in my mini raishin
Loretta McLaughlin come over man I'm
joining the 2 meter in a letter my
problem my difficulty take up when I'm
in BA
well she when I'm gay you couldn't warn
him um when joking it too politically
and cook with somewhere and Geoghan into
pedagogues an indica to mix but even if
they stay healthy
the twins face a lifetime of hard labor
as soon as they can walk the children's
cobalt is sold cheaply to mostly Chinese
traders who reform secretly they don't
ask questions about where their cobalt
comes from or whose work to extract it
they just want the best price even those
who aren't Chinese this trading market
has Indian owners told us they sell on
to the dominant Chinese exporter of
cobalt CDM the cobalt first mined here
is then sold again to the Chinese parent
company which then supplies some of the
world's biggest battery makers and those
batteries with ingredients which
originated in DRC end up in for instance
smartphones it's an intricate supply
chain which allows easy deniability for
the multinationals making huge profits
an investigation last year by amnesty
found similar human rights abuses
nothing appears to have changed
most of these child minors will never
own a smartphone they barely survived
from day to day and many other children
like Dawson will be back again tomorrow
digging out one of the most sought-after
minerals of our time for a pittance
Alex Crawford Sky News in the DRC